one of the men who accused Oscar winner
Kevin Spacey of sexually assaulting him
when he was a teenager allegedly
captured the incident on camera a newly
released police report shows the victim
told investigators he sent video of some
of the alleged 2016 assault to his
girlfriend on snapchat Spacey is charged
with indecent assault and battery
David beg know shows us what else is
revealed in the police report David good
morning Dana good morning the alleged
assault happened at the restaurant where
the victim worked on Monday we found out
Spacey is being charged with a crime and
that same day he put out a video on
YouTube titled let me be frank you
trusted me even though you knew you
shouldn't win Kevin Spacey posted this
video to his Twitter account shortly
after a felony sexual assault charge was
announced against him he seemed to be in
character I don't have as Frank
Underwood from his former series house
of cards but you wouldn't believe the
worst without evidence would you you
wouldn't rush to judgments without facts
would you here are the allegations
spacey sexually assaulted an 18 year old
man in a Nantucket Massachusetts
restaurant in July of 2016 according to
a police report obtained Wednesday by
mass live the victim claims Spacey
unzipped his pants and touched his groin
without consent while the two of them
stood around a piano the victim told
police he captured snapchat video of
Spacey touching him and he sent it to
his girlfriend who also spoke to
investigators shame on you for what you
did to my son
former Boston TV news anchor Heather
Unruh revealed in a news conference last
year that her son is Spacey's alleged
victim Kevin Spacey bought him drink
after drink after drink and when my son
was drunk Spacey made his move the
victim told police he left the bar as
Kevin Spacey went to the bathroom Spacey
allegedly sent a text to the victim
saying I think we lost each other the
victim had gone home and told his sister
he was raped by Kevin Spacey
cease the 59 year-old actor's career
collapsed last year amid more than a
dozen other sexual misconduct
allegations you're out here attempt here
actor Anthony Rapp was the first accuser
to come forward alleging that Spacey
assaulted him when he was just 14 years
old Spacey apologized to rap in a tweet
saying he did not remember the incident
I was just hopeful that coming forward
it would encourage other people to tell
the truth I was trying to protect people
now Spacey is due in court on January
7th on a felony charge of indecent
assault and battery now the actor could
get up to five years in prison if
convicted he remains under investigation
on suspicion of sexual assault in Los
Angeles for an incident that allegedly
happened in 2016
I called Spacey cell phone this morning
nobody answered our team of producers
reached out to him and his attorneys
yesterday left messages no response
there either maybe I'll send you a video
that video is more than bizarre who does
that
he plays unusual characters and it would
appear he may be an unusual character
himself I mean look he hadn't been
convicted of anything but but on the
same day you find out he's gonna be
charged that video really disturb that
strange extremely troubling everyday the
worst news David Beck knows thank you